and the man who has the honor the
reigning champion
with aaron rodgers from last summer
bryson d chambeau welcome back to the
match bryson
thanks guys glad to be back it's going
to be a lot of fun today and we're going
to see uh
who gets it done today for sure the
driver's in hand quite a bit here today
it's going to be a lot of fun
get some i toad it a bit but it'll do
[Laughter]
it's all right
wow
that's six eight feet by
very well though they don't uh
appreciate just how good he is at these
however this one's a tricky one
and that's right on it
it's got action here
oh my god wow
needed that
bryson d chambo
chant set up ernie here at the par three
[Music]
[Music]
this to have the hole
dude
perfect and it draws perfectly so it's
right down the center he's gonna have
even shorter than i said oh look out
coming right into your living room
oh
i mean that is so attractive
absolutely perfect
so this is slinging with the green
he's got to get about big belts
we'll clip the tree there oh a good
bounce though
down to the front
that could have easily kicked right wow
now this
window is not an easy shot guys
get left
all right
whoa
okay wow that is a lot of spin on it
bryson needs something good to happen
quickly here he's three down he's got a
great angle of his pin he can play a
little long right of the pin and have it
come right back to the hole
too on do your thing
ah it didn't roll up yeah it did yeah
see
see what happened you just breathe and
hit the shot
[Applause]
come on spin
okay i'm so surprised he's kind of
caught this up it comes back to like ten
ten feet
ah it's got that
stop spinning shoot all right
tried going for it just hold it man
it did not bank right
brooks good job man
enjoy playing yeah
appreciate it moment of truth
this could go anywhere
literally
that's right
i miss it so bad
what was the ball speed on that
205. 205.
just pushed it
[Applause]
nice lily
all right
i'll tell you anything else can we hit
it like another it's impressive brooks
is just a tough tough competitor there's
an intangible there that he's the guy
that there's very few guys that want the
most pressure
that